[Music]
the most remarkable fact about the
decline of men in America is how
relentlessly our leaders pretend it's
not happening at all the patriarchy is
thriving they tell us men are in charge
and they succeed precisely to the extent
they thought the progress of women
society is a zero-sum equation in which
a man's gain is a woman's loss this is
wrong and we must rectify it
that's the message those also happen to
be the core assumptions of second wave
feminism which became popular 40 years
ago just as many of our baby-boom
leaders were coming of age and yet none
of those assumptions are true today
America has changed completely the
patriarchy is gone women are winning men
are failing men in America are now far
more likely to die of a drug overdose
drop out of the workforce because of an
addiction commit a felony and go to
prison they fail in school much more
often than women do they kill themselves
at many times the rate overall they die
years younger those numbers are not
speculative they are hard data gathered
over decades by nonpartisan researchers
you'd have to ignore a huge amount of
settled science or to repeat the piety
of 1970s era feminism and yet that is
exactly what our leaders continue to do
in March of 2009 almost immediately
after arriving in Washington Barack
Obama created the White House Council on
women and girls he tapped his advisor
Valerie Jarrett to run it quote when our
daughters don't have the same education
and career opportunities as our sons
Obama said in his announcement that
affects our economy and our future as a
nation at the very moment Obama was
lamenting the lack of educational
opportunities for women more girls than
boys were graduating from high school
far more were graduating from college
women now earned 62% of associate's
degrees 57 percent of bachelor's degrees
60 percent of master's degrees and 52%
of doctorates that gap is even wider in
non-white neighborhoods for example in
2007 among black and Hispanic graduates
of public schools in Boston for every
100 black men who got a college degree
there were 230 black women who got one
for every 100 Hispanic men
who got a college degree there were 211
Hispanic women who got one 70% of all
master's degrees awarded to black
students nationally went to black women
just 30% went to black men yet for
reasons the Obama administration never
explained the school performance of
black and Hispanic girls was deemed a
higher priority than performance of
black and Hispanic boys under Obama the
White House solicited hundreds of
millions of dollars from corporations to
encourage female achievement in higher
education at the time this was happening
one study showed that they were already
at least four times as many privately
funded college scholarships available
for girls as for boys four times the
administration never acknowledged this
instead it sought new ways to close a
gender gap that no longer exists one
idea was quote breaking down gender
stereotypes in toys to that end the
White House pressured manufacturers
retailers and media outlets to eliminate
gender distinction in children's toys
this the administration claimed would
allow kids to quote explore learn and
dream without limits well educators at
all levels took this idea seriously in
2015 one kindergarten teacher in
Washington State
banned her male students from playing
with Lego fitting together plastic
blocks has been found by researchers to
help children develop important
cognitive skills boys have enough
advantages the teacher explained so she
intentionally prevented them from
learning girls thrive when boys fail
this is the underlying assumption of
much of America's gender policy and
education there is no credible research
to suggest that is true it is purely an
ideological belief and yet that
assumption is pervasive especially on
college campuses now that's ironic
because there are more than two million
more women than
enrolled in college this year on most
campuses men are a distinct minority at
carlow University in Pittsburgh women
outnumber men by more than six to one
and yet almost every campus has a
Women's Studies department in many of
them the stated goal is to fight
expressions of masculinity and
disempower men at Ohio State of course
is underway this spring called
be a man masculinities race and nation
the syllabus for that course explains
that masculinity is used to quote
justify certain kinds of violence by men
on the first day of class students were
required to consult a male priviledge
checklist at Duke University in North
Carolina a nine week workshop met to
devise ways to undermine quote
masculinity and maleness as well as to
create destabilized spaces for those
with privileged meaning men similar
projects have sprouted at colleges all
over the country under the Obama
administration the Department of Justice
created something called the healthy
masculinity campus athletics project the
coordinator of that program at Wheaton
College summed up its objective this way
quote as a country we need to do a
better job of addressing issues around
toxic masculinity left unasked was the
most basic question of all is
masculinity itself really toxic and what
happens to boys when we tell them that
it is it's widely understood that
attacking people for their basic nature
is unhealthy and it's wrong a government
funded program designed to fight toxic
femininity or toxic homosexuality
probably would not escape the scrutiny
of Congress or the media at the very
least its supporters would have to
explain why our country needs a program
like that and yet nobody has been forced
to explain why boys who are already
failing need to be held back further and
so they are christina hoff sommers is
the author of the war against boys she
was one of the very first people in
American intellectual life to notice
this trend and to sound the alarm
she was ignored but we're grateful that
she did it anyway thank you christina
hoff sommers joins us tonight so you you
wrote this original piece from which
this whole series basically has been
derived almost 20 years ago when you
notice that boys are falling behind
and yet the assumptions of the people
who make policy decisions don't seem to
have changed much in that time why
there's a great deal of resistance to
addressing the needs of boys and and
there are a lot of women's groups not
all of them but most of them call it
backlash and they're unwilling to listen
so boys we chose if we've we've thrown
the gender switch and boys are on the
wrong side of the gender gap in a joke
or assumption is that it's a zero-sum
arrangement where when you hold back
boys girls shoot ahead and it's great
for them but that's not only the nature
of life is it doesn't help girls find
boys have a fundamental fallacy see
there I think too many of the activist
groups think that there's a trophy and
either Venus is going to win or Mars and
their job is to root for Venus and make
sure you hold back Mars no there's not a
single trophy men and women boys and
girls we're in this together and if boys
are in trouble so are we all I mean
these are the young men with whom our
daughters and granddaughters are going
to make the future and so if boys are
failing but what's going to happen to
girls that's a great that's a question
that a father of every daughter
including myself thinks about a lot so I
you sort of wonder like how do we get to
a place where colleges in which broadly
speaking men really are failing falling
behind girls have funded departments
whose main course of study is why
masculinity maleness is bad why doesn't
anybody ever say anything about that we
try but again you're you're you're
called names and demonized if you if you
defend boys and point out their plight
specifically in education and we have
economists now Larry Summers for example
projects whether that by mid-century it
may be a third of the of men in the
full-time workforce are gonna be out of
the workforce i disengaged not their
millions of men are simply not gonna be
looking for work not not in in the
workplace now we can address this
England Australia Canada they're very
worried about because of the future of
their economy and because of the social
you know just confusion that this
will lead to and they're addressing the
problem they haven't solved it but
they're working on it we haven't really
acknowledged it what does it say about
our policymakers that they're acting
from assumptions that were relevant in
1979 but are no longer well they're
they're not paying attention and I think
it's it's not it's hard to know where to
place the fault because there's simply
what we have right now is vast numbers
of organizations that have actually done
a very good job supporting young women
and helping young women addressing their
needs girls we're behind in math and
science and thanks to many women's
groups and activists we have
strengthened young women they take more
advanced math classes and science
classes than boys now in school where
were the efforts for boys there weren't
the there was no Lobby
there's no Lobby and people say well
they don't need a lobby it's a man's
world well I'm not sure that's true but
altogether but it's certainly not a
little boy's world and no one's paying
attention said well thank you for all
the work you've done in this it's
important Christina of summers thanks
thank you